but speaking of concern let's begin this
hour with the latest on the monkey pox
outbreak which the white house is now
calling a public health emergency the
goal is to make vaccines and treatments
more readily available the virus has
been detected in all but two states and
the number of infections is rising
rapidly more than seven thousand cases
have been reported across the u.s and
health officials warned that that number
will go up as testing improves
dr xia is the white house covet response
coordinator and he is also assisting the
response to the monkey pox virus dr jah
how are you doing good morning
good morning thanks for having me here
now that this is declared a public
health emergency what changes when it
comes to monkey pox
yeah it's it's one more tool in our
toolbox of of all the things that the
administration is doing to ramp up the
response right we just named
two
key national leaders to lead the
response out of the white house one from
fema one from cdc
the public health emergency allows us to
speed up vaccines and treatments uh more
effectively and efficiently that's going
to be helpful
and and also helps us get data better
data collected better across the country
so there's a whole set of tools that the
public health emergency gives us
that allows us to be even more effective
in this response
dr john you said a couple of weeks ago
on face the nation we can we think we
can get our arms around this thing where
are we
on vaccines and and how are you
prioritizing them
the goal of this is still to eliminate
this virus to get it under control and
to ultimately eliminate it
in terms of vaccines we have
substantially ramped up both vaccine
acquisition from abroad so there's one
small company in denmark that makes
these vaccines
we have gotten more vaccines than the
rest of the world combined
and we're primarily targeting those
vaccines to the community where this
virus is spreading
which is largely among gay and bisexual
men who have sex with men that's where
the virus is spreading and that's where
most of the localities most of the
cities and states are getting the
vaccines out
somebody watching right now may think
okay we have roughly 7 000 cases in the
country based on what you just said is
this a bit of an overreaction are we
pulling the fire alarms so to speak
declaring this massive public health
emergency
when
it's not as much of a threat to
everybody around the country your
reaction
yeah i would say two things i mean first
of all thankfully no one has died so we
are still at a point in this in this
outbreak
where i do believe that while it is very
very serious it is not something
that is reason for widespread alarm
but look public health emergency gives
us some tools that lets us get on top of
this thing one of the lessons we learned
from covid one of the lessons that we
learned from all outbreaks always better
to be a step ahead of the virus and
that's what we're doing here we're
taking this very very seriously it's
obviously affecting a specific community
we're working very closely with that
community i think this is absolutely the
right and appropriate approach it will
allow us to give us even more tools to
get on top of this virus
dr zhao where are we with antivirals
yeah it's a very good question there's
one treatment called tpox uh it is
actually a treatment for smallpox has
not been authorized for
for monkeypox fda is looking at that
collecting data the good news again our
our administration was prepared we have
1.7 million doses of that in the
strategic national stockpile we're going
to be studying how well it's working
we're still getting that out to people
looking at the data making sure it's
safe and effective we believe it is all
the data so far says it is
and the goal is to make sure that those
antivirals continue to get out to people
who are infected
dr john there is a lot of confusion on
how this virus actually spreads the cdc
says you can get it from touching
objects or even fabrics which is all of
us every single day can you clarify that
yeah look there is a theoretical risk
and then there's the reality i mean
theoretically sure you can spread
through those mechanisms but when you
actually look at the data and say how is
this virus actually spreading right 98
of the cases so far have been among gay
and bisexual men it is largely spreading
through prolonged skin to skin contact
the reality is a lot of people want this
vaccine they want it now so if you go
out today
long lines are already forming
where can you get it and how fast can
you get it
[Music]
yeah so we're getting it out to
localities i mean by that cities and
states right and they're making the
determination of where which communities
but i want to again re-emphasize to me
the most important thing is that this
vaccine get out to the communities where
the virus is spreading and that is again
among gay and bisexual men and that's
what most communities that's what most
localities public health departments
that that's the group that
most of them are targeting and i think
that's appropriate i think that's where
vaccines should be
but but where's dr ja specifically
you're speaking to
several million people right now where
can folks
get this vaccine yeah so again different
public health departments have set it up
differently i would look up your public
local public health department almost
every
state has a website on monkeypox you can
go to that it'll tell you where vaccines
are available every jurisdiction every
city every state in the country
certainly every state in the country has
been allocated vaccines and they have
all set up their own places of where
they're getting these vaccines out
we appreciate you always being here when
we need you dr thank you
thank you